today on drew we're flashing back to our
favorite moments from season one
only eddie murphy could get me literally
rolling on the floor plus our two-week
premiere event starts monday from
hollywood we're revealing superstar
guest like one of the most talented
singers in the world
billy eilish it all starts now
[Music]
please welcome drew barrymore
hello everyone season two of our first
show is just four days away on monday
september 13th we're kicking off a brand
new season full of surprises signature
segments and yes stain removal
the stain busting will never stop don't
you worry
all right we're having a big two week
premiere event paying homage to all of
our favorite home towns and that feeling
that there's no place like home well
we're starting in my hometown of la and
we're ending up here
in our show's hometown and my new
hometown of new york city
hello
i do heart new york
this week we're having a little
pre-party and celebrating our favorite
moments from season one let's kick
things off with a guest who had some
great advice
about the importance of celebrating
ourselves and here's our very candid
conversation with the legendary the
hilarious
and wise eddie murphy take a look
i was lucky enough
to meet our first guest when i was just
seven years old
he was a couple of seasons into his
transformative run on saturday night
live where he immortalized characters
like mr robinson
and gumby
but he was destined for even greater
things and
he found them um as the star as some of
the most iconic comedies of all time
let's talk about trading places
let's talk about beverly hills cop
let's talk about coming to america
and he still pursued his first love
stand up and released two specials
including the highest grossing stand-up
comedy concert film of all time
and then the father of ten
gifted his talents to beloved family
films that shaped generations voicing
characters and films like mulan
and the shrek franchise
and now after celebrated performances in
2006's dream girls and 2019's dolomite
is my name he is returning to his
kingdom zamunda
as prince akeem and coming to america
this is one of my very favorite movies
of all times i have a date with lisa i
can't believe i'm saying this in front
of the person please
welcome the one of a kind eddie murphy
that is so nice you made made me feel
like
hello eddie murphy
i'm so happy to see you
yeah happy to see you too
i mean
1982 just a
you and i
you're just a baby
i'm kind of young too i think i'm like
19 or 20 there yeah i remember tim
kazarinski you you kind of like you guys
were buddies
that we became buddies with him i did i
gravitated towards him he was so nice to
me
you guys are cute do you remember doing
the e
uh t sketch you were mr t
looking for his boy e
and um
i don't know if you remember this but
steven spielberg was there um he was
very protective of me at that time i was
so lucky you know what's so strange
about uh the whole snl experience so
long ago and uh
so there'll be sometimes it'll be like a
sketch on and i won't even remember the
sketch i'll be watching it going what is
what is the sketch and how what happens
next it's like so much it's so long ago
and so many sketches in between that and
so much stuff a lot of times i don't
remember it i don't remember that mr t
sketch i just remember everything from
that show
very vividly but i too have like you
know surrealistic
people
yeah
i can imagine you're a little baby when
you started
well and that was in 1982.
i know and you have 10 kids so i can
only imagine what your perspective is
now because i have two daughters and my
perspective is completely different now
than when i was seven well i'm totally
different for not just ten kids i have
my grandchild at my first grandchild
she calls me papa
that's so
wonderful
i was reading that you said like your
house is just a hub of activity and that
you like to hear the voices just all
over the place and how proud you are of
your kids and all 10
turned out really wonderful people yeah
that's my my favorite thing of all
is to have no schedule have nothing i
have to do and i'm home
and uh all my kids and all their their
friends that they're all around and i
can hear where everybody's at that's
that's nirvana for me
and i was reading about how
that you lean into being a spiritual
person and
um
being centered and that you
said maybe you avoided some of the
pitfalls that were so easy at your
disposal if you will
because of spirituality is that is that
true
yeah i'm very grounded spiritually and
not so much you know any religion just a
connection you know with uh with god you
know being a young person in this
business and
it's a lot it's like you got to navigate
through a minefield you know so many
ways you could just you know
destroy yourself
a lot of the people
that that i've seen that destroyed
themselves a lot of my contemporaries a
bunch of my contemporaries with people
like michael and
prince and whitney and people that came
on the scene around the same age that i
am
you know
they kind of you know it was this
self-destructive thing that they had you
know
that's my biggest blessing that i got
started really early i knew what i
wanted to do really really young and
that i loved myself i never hated myself
i never beat up on myself i never was
i always i've always been my biggest fan
[Laughter]
i love that you deserve to be um because
we're all there with you
what would you say to someone who like
does struggle with
like call itself love i i'm asking for
myself because i
love and respect myself but i fall off
the wagon with total self-flagellation
and like
you know being too hard and not meeting
my own expectations do you have any
advice for me
it's an inward search
in uh
and it's personal and it's just between
you and you
and the outside stuff you have to learn
to not
like i don't i don't even let i don't
let anything
that's not constructive i don't let
anything negative in you have to train
yourself to turn away from it when you
when negative stuff comes in stuff
that's not constructive you have to turn
from it
you're here and then you're blessed
you're here and you're blessed you
already won
so the negative energy
is no time for that you won already i
know what you do every morning you
should do a you should do a victory
dance you should wake up every morning
and do the truth very much victory day
[Laughter]
you won mama i
feel like the world's biggest winner
right now to hear
such salient advice from someone i
have respected so much my whole life and
in 1982 when you were when we did
saturday night live together then you
know you had done 48 hours trading
places um
uh beverly hills cop um by the way
you're delirious right in the middle of
that the red leather suit is right in
the middle of that and what exact point
was raw to that right after coming to
america oh yeah so that's 87.
i could tell because i have a perm my
hair is
good
you had such a succession of these epic
films you know you're so young
do you ever come down
from those
periods of time where you have hit after
hit after hit and you're working working
working
i'll tell you what happened i'll tell
you what happened to me uh
i had it all the way together for years
and years and years and then what
happened with movies is uh
they started me offering you so much
money to do stuff that i i wound up
doing all you know what that's like you
just still be like you want to give me
you want to give me that much money to
do that
okay so
wow
bunch of movies like that and it's
forever like way after the way after the
money is spent that movie is like still
playing on a movie channel so it's like
so i had i got to where i stopped having
fun making movies so i had to take
i had to take a time like about in 2011
i think it was
uh
i stopped
for like eight years i just stopped
making movies
and that's where i had really really
quiet time and got re-centered
to where you know if i'm going to be
doing something i want to be doing it
because i want to do it and all that and
it got my i got it all back together
that way that is the perfect answer to
that question and the reason i asked is
because
you know since that 1982 time and i had
even been working before that and so had
you but
we're still here we're still going it's
30 40 years later or 40 years later i
said well i said you should do the
victory dance how about this we're in
the business drew where people come and
go
people come and go every five years it's
a brand new bunch of new faces and it's
a brand new and anybody that's in this
business for as long as you've been in
this business as long as i've been in
this business i think you know that
means that we're not stinky
has been firmly established that we are
not stinky
it was
very special advice to hear from eddie
and the truth is i still forget it all
the time i need to write it on my wall
because he's right
we don't feel like we have accomplished
enough or that we're there at those goal
lines we push and push and push and
really take ourselves down and we need
to lift ourselves up all right i love
that advice from eddie all right now sit
tight because we're just getting started
there's more eddie murphy and behind the
scenes tidbits to his famous films in
just a minute we'll be right back
i have a date with lisa will you say it
with me i'll have a nice day like this i
have a date with lisa no i'll do it i
know
lisa
[Applause]
the first time
[Music]
we're back to bring you more
[Music]
the new season of drew premieres
september 13th
welcome back
we're checking out some of the most
memorable moments from season one
curated just for you of the drew
barrymore show with bonus directors cut
commentary from someone with a unique
firsthand perspective
me
now let's jump back into our
conversation with eddie murphy where i
may or may not have gotten him to do one
of my favorite lines that i say every
day from coming to america
okay spoiler alert i did take a look
one of my favorite movies of all time is
coming to america coming to america too
is um
is here and we can all finally go back
to zamunda
was there
a moment where you said now is the right
time to make this sequel
no it kind of happened organically this
movie the way it came because the way
the story ended it was kind of like that
it was and they live happily ever after
and we didn't even think about making a
sequel but then the movie came like a
cult movie like little stuff from the
movie just stayed around of all the
movies that i've done
none of them no movie is on tv as much
as coming to america it's always on and
little lines from the movie people are
sexual chocolate people say it had a
little line from the movie or the mic
drop that everybody does the the mic
drop the very first mic drop ever is
randy watson from coming to america
all this all this little stuff from the
movie and then what happened
about 10 years ago
people started some people on halloween
would dress up as the characters and
there's a restaurant in l.a that on
halloween it changes itself into
mcdowell's and they have like a
mcdowell's menu so it really is like
this like cult movie so
uh it became that and that's when i
started having the idea but you know the
people that really really like that
movie might you know want to see a
sequel to it and then we when we figured
out a way to connect the dots and then
to make it make sense
then we
wrote wrote a script and it came
together right can i ask um a burning
question that i've wondered ever since i
first saw the movie which is the little
child on the skateboard because they've
all taken the suitcases um and they're
wearing all the
fabulous the munda garb
was it like let's just say that we have
so much clothes that they're our child
sizes or screw it tailor it funnier
license we're taking license there
because i know it's as a kid and he has
a little a child's side
you have to remember now that the movie
was a comedy and it was directed by the
great john landis john lennon that was a
people uh when they talk about coming to
america when i'm asked about coming to
america they get me and arsenio like the
actors that get all the credit for the
movie and that movie is
that movie is
more john landis than anything and
that's a john landis joke to have the
kids go skating by and at the end and
the moment he probably was they have a
kid's skateboard
he's like that it's my favorite moment
other than of course the quote of i have
a date with lisa and it's um
i say it every day because it's my
version of showing that i'm happy
that's wonderful
oh we have the clip may we show it
please
i have a date with lisa
isn't that wonderful
you know that scene right there at uh
the little girls that are in that scene
uh was a friend of mine named named
jeffrey moore who lived in brooklyn and
he stopped by the set that day and the
little girl in the in the light blue
jacket that was his daughter she was
just with him we just put her in the
scene like right there it just happened
at that moment would you ever say it
with me will you say it with me how
could i say it like this
i have a david lease
i have a date with lisa no i'll do it i
know
lisa
[Applause]
yeah if i knew you was gonna roll around
i did it the first time
eddie i
i'm so happy to see you thank you for
giving me such incredible salient life
advice it's nice to see you too and i i
look forward to after all this uh
pandemic stuff is over come there and
see you live in person
i will roll myself up in this carpet for
you i'll be like a burrito by the time
we finish and i will dance that victory
dance and um
recognize the purpose and and if you
don't do it physically do it you know
get ready to always start the day with
i've already won this at this game i've
already won
now it's just about you know
getting the most out of everything you
know being here and your your babies and
your family i i very much recognize that
and i i love it coming from the person
who has made life make sense for so many
of us on this planet by helping us love
and laugh and enjoy life and fall in
love with the extraordinary characters
that are you that you've put out into
the world thank you thank you so much
oh only eddie murphy could get me
literally rolling on the floor like the
carpet was a burrito all right more of
our favorite moments when we return
don't move
[Music]
we're back to bring you more
[Music]
the new season of drew premieres
september 13th
cookbooks are my obsession and it turns
out i'm not alone watch this
my cook book club is
ina garten barefoot contessa modern
comfort food it has everything you
exactly want to be eating right now and
you might look up the best tomato soup
with a grilled cheese but aina always
makes it that much easier to make and
with an ingredient you wouldn't have
expected so it's that much more
delicious it is ideal
she does this chicken breast with orzo
that i did on my pretend cooking show
and i've made my chicken breasts that
way so many times since then and i made
it last night and my kids and i were
just like this is delicious
and all the desserts the way she does
potatoes in that cookbook for veggies
ina garten barefoot contessa modern
comfort food
favorite cookbook right now
thank you for joining in my obsession
with cookbooks
welcome back to our season two pre-party
we're checking out some of our favorite
season one moments and letting you in on
behind the scenes secrets ahead of our
season two premiere next week one of my
favorite parts of this job is getting to
meet so many incredible and inspiring
people
from everywhere and this person who's
coming up next really really affected me
i love her deborah houston is a mother
grandmother great grandmother and get
this the oldest soapbox derby racer in
the country take a look
here she is it's debra
hi drew
hi debra
i'm so excited to meet you
and i'm excited to meet you too
how did you end up getting into soapbox
racing
well you know indianapolis is known for
the racing
and a friend of mine had approached me
about taking my grandchildren to do the
soapbox racing
and um
so i i thought it would be a good thing
for them to get them off the computers
you know it'll teach them responsibility
and you know give them something to do
during the pandemic so
i took them to practice and they met
their coach mr larry
and mr larry kept approaching me about
racing he said you the perfect size
he said come on do it and i i kept
thinking about it thinking about it and
i finally said okay i'll try it
i love it because i mean i i learned
that like the oldest soapbox racer in
your team is 14 right
right
i just love this this is so cool tiny
but mighty now yes what was going
through their head the first time you're
like
well at first i was i was a little
nervous and i was hyperventilating
because i wasn't so nervous and
i i i went down that hill
and when i went down that hill i said oh
i can do this i can do this and i
started practicing and kept going down
the hill and it turned out to be fun
i i was at the same time i was going
through chemo so
i said well you know rather than sit up
and work and worry about chemo i could
be practicing and having fun and you
know just doing this with my
grandchildren and
i really enjoyed it
and
is it true that you're doing
fantastically well now
yes i am cancer-free
yes
i'm i i asked that right away when i
found out and it's just so important and
your story your attitude the fact that
you want to get your kids out of the
technology and out into the world during
the pandemic the fact that you had
cancer and we're going through this but
chose to spend your time doing and
focusing on this you are the example
thank you girl thank you thank you true
puppy you are what's next for you what
else are we gonna learn from you
well i'm gonna i'm gonna go race this
2021
and this year i'm gonna win
so
it's to race
and to win in 2021. well you are
the biggest winner and we want to be
cheering you on and i have a little
something for you oh really for me yeah
this is um a little
name oh yeah it does um i hope you don't
mind we put a little logo of our show on
there here you go
that's a racist suit and it's just
perfectly your size and i will say it's
sturdy but it's also really soft
oh my goodness thank you thank you drew
it is such a pleasure but that's not all
check this out so
we know you live in indianapolis so we
reached out to the indy 500
when they heard about you they wanted to
give you a few things as well so
they want to have you wave the green
flag for the indy 500 practice day yeah
that's right
oh my goodness
oh my goodness how cool is that and they
also really cool oh that just makes me
feel so good
thank you
well they also want to put your soapbox
on display in their fan area on actual
race day
and host you and all your grandchildren
on practice day and show you off like a
little debra museum
thank you so much thank you
oh deborah do you mind if we speak to
you again and ask you how that day went
and you know just check in
yes oh you can please call me please
call me
please please call me i'm so
okay good i'm so related like debra i
need more i want to like catch up and
see how that day went and
um thank you to the indy 500 who gets it
wants to honor deborah we honor you here
at this show we love you and i can't
thank you enough for being here to
uh be that example
well thank you drew and thank you for
having me and thank you for all of that
thank you so much oh thank you deborah
deborah is the best and we followed up
with her after her big day at the indy
500 and she told us she felt like a true
celebrity and queen that day and they
actually showed her drew barrymore show
appearance on the big screens at the
race racetrack and she said all the
professional drivers were asking to take
pictures with her
so fun and just so deserved we're
rooting for you debra
more um behind the scenes in just a
minute okay we'll see you in a second
hopefully all right
[Music]
welcome back do you watch our show and
wonder what happens after the cameras
stop rolling
well
all week long we're revisiting some of
our favorite season one moments and
sharing behind the scenes bonus
commentary now you probably know by now
i don't know if you know but i am a
beauty junkie so i always look forward
to our segment called beauty in a box
where i get to customize the perfect
beauty routine for one of you and send
it right to your door in a care package
and then take you through it and our
first ever beauty in a box segment was
with a viewer named daniela who wrote to
us with a very relatable beauty dilemma
take a look
hi drew my name is daniella i'm 40 years
old i live in illinois i am a working
mom with four kids
i need some help with makeup i need a
five minute routine that will
enhance the most features um because
five minutes is about as much time as i
have with four kids and working
also if you can help me with mascara i
hate putting it on it smudges and i look
like a raccoon within an hour it's just
underneath my eyes so if i have to wear
it please teach me how to use it
thank you and
i really need your help
daniella i have to tell you you are so
beautiful i've seen your video before
but as i'm re-watching it i'm just like
you're so pretty
thank you
that's a
very big compliment coming from drew
barrymore well
what i put together for you do you have
a box in front of you we sent you some
beauty products
yeah i do
all right
this is beauty in a box shall we open it
together yes please okay
so what i got for you first is
i love the company keels um and this is
a skin tone
and uh beautifying bb cream but it also
has sunscreen do you wear sunscreen i do
that's probably the only thing that i'm
very consistent about oh my god i'm so
proud of you and happy for you because
i'm terrible about it unless i'm going
into the sun i always forget
so
tinted moisturizers and light bb creams
with sunscreen are just great for daily
wear and they're going to be a really
light layer you can literally put it
into your hands like a moisturizer
and then do the pat pat pat and then
you'll go under the eyes and you can
always add more
you look amazing
wow isn't that that's crazy
okay i am so pleased do you what do you
think do you like it well it's nice
because it's it's light it feels really
nice on it's very moisturizing okay now
next what i got you is this is a company
called amazing amazing concealer
and this is for if you ever have more
sleepless nights or you're just a little
more exhausted or you get a blemish and
what's nice is that the pigment is nice
and
heavy so it'll cover up dark circles or
a spot but it's very blendable on the
edges otherwise you're going to see the
circle so under my app yeah just a teeny
dot dot dot and then you can work it in
with your fingers very minimal this is
for
those [ __ ] keeper days when the kids
have exhausted you oh my god you look so
beautiful i'm so excited i swear i feel
like
i don't know i feel like
like an artist right now and like i'm
painting you and like i'm like look at
this a painting she's so beautiful oh my
god you really i'm so happy right now
because you are already so beautiful and
i want things that will not take away
from your natural beauty okay this one
is actually from flower beauty it's
called um gel crush and the reason i
love this it's brand new for our company
you take it off it's great for the bag i
also love a good purse friendly makeup
when you have a foundation the size of
this you're probably not throwing it in
your purse
so this is dot dot dot dot dot dot and a
little smudge on the lips
just so if you want a pop of color you
know you can get it out of this
oh daniella you are looking so foxy
i'm so
pleased right now i feel like a proud
peacock
is it too much or no no not at all
that's great and then work it all over
the lips like um
like a deodorant fell in love with a
lipstick and had a baby
yes
that just gave that perfect little kick
where it sort of picks up your natural
pigment the thing that i care the most
about with flower beauty is that it will
never leave a woman hanging when we have
a formula it never like gathers or goes
in the cracks the pigment just goes away
the hydration stays okay
next from flower i got you our lash
warrior and the reason i love this is it
looks like a weapon because it is it is
an amazing mascara and it actually has
a rubber wand um which is going to
distribute through the lash differently
and it's going to lead to less flakage
i think you're doing a phenomenal job
okay now at the end i put this in
special this is micellar water i
discovered this because all the people
in the fashion industry for the runway
fashion shows were using this because
they could take off all the makeup in
one felt swoop and it used to only be
available in france and now micellar
waters are always on trend so this is a
garnier you can find this anywhere so
when you're done with all of this you
want to put this
on the pad and you want to just take
everything off and make it nice and
clean and clear no matter what you do do
not go to bed with your makeup on
no it's usually pretty easy because i
normally don't wear makeup but
no i do wash i do have a good cleansing
routine it's just some it's just makeup
i have a hard time with it but this is
something i can totally do on my own and
quick with four kids thank you so much
that's exactly the point natural fast
and absolutely beautiful you already
were and this just enhances that and
really the whole point of beauty is how
you feel
and if something happens where it boosts
the way you feel that is the whole point
as far as i'm concerned thank you so
much this was great i feel great
yay daniela and you please keep writing
us with your beauty dilemmas because
we'll be sending out more beauty boxes
in season two and i cannot wait
let me be your personal beauty junkie
all right more fun from season one in
just a second as they say stay right
there we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back we're getting ready for our
season two premiere next week by looking
back on some of our favorite moments
from season one with some fun bonus
facts
as a business owner myself i am so
passionate about highlighting inspiring
entrepreneurs and when we heard about
cindy tawiah we knew that we had to talk
to her she is a beauty brand founder who
launched the first ever natural hair
care vending machines in the u.s and her
genius idea to put her products in a
vending machine
came as a result of a disappointing
setback that she faced
talk about ingenuity i do believe that
failure can lead to success and there is
no success without failure check out our
conversation with cindy and the special
surprise that we had in store for her
please welcome cindy tawiah hi cindy
hi true hi
oh my god you're cute i just got to tell
you i just have to thank you
your products are in sally's beauty
supplies and walmart.com
um and so are we at flower beauty so i'm
very happy to be sisters in business
with you
and oh
thank you drew i've looked into getting
a vending machine and it is no easy feat
oh my goodness trey well
i had a wonderful successful thriving
blooming store at bwi airport and i put
that story there because tsa takes away
all our hair care products and it's so
traumatic i know you've been through it
i know you've
they're like you can't take this through
yeah yeah
yes so i opened the store everything was
going great and then one day they took
away my store it was like you know we're
reclaiming the space and i was
devastated i had to lay everybody off
and literally close my store and you
know what
a girl's got to get on her feet after a
few months i went right back to that
airport met with the ceo mr ricky put my
powerpoint presentation in his face and
i said this is what i want to bring here
and he looked at me he said young lady
you're very persistent how many airports
do you want how many concourses you want
i said that's it amen we're in so that's
how that all started i love you
engineering
girls gotta get creative you know they
take away from you you gotta figure out
how to bring it back yeah you gotta
pivot right if you wanna be successful
and i know your business
is successful and and a core part of it
is not only providing products for women
but taking care of women as well why is
that important to you oh my god roz i'm
a survivor domestic violence but one of
the things that's very very important is
we donate 10 of our proceeds to homeless
shelters and then we do beauty makeovers
it's called the diva project where we go
out and we give them a full beauty
makeover and it's so important for us to
give back to our community and
especially women who are hurting and
broken
i mean
right i mean i'm
i
i love you i love you
i just have so much admiration for you i
don't know where to begin
thank you so much
and i you
because sisters have to take care of
sisters women have to pour into each
other instead of tearing each other down
we have to build each other up that's
how we rise
well you're such a caretaker i mean you
weren't always in the beauty industry
right you were a nurse for 13 years yes
i was a nurse for 13 years and what led
me to this point was
um you know i had a chemistry teacher
who taught me how to make nail polish
and lipstick when i was 16 years old in
ghana west africa
this teacher mr of fed
he saw that i was struggling and instead
of giving me another f which i had been
getting by the way
he said young lady i'm going to teach
you how to make nail polish and lipstick
and you're going to learn to love my
class and then when he was done he had
me be part of the science fair that was
for the bright intelligent students not
for dodos like me so of course at the
science fair he presented me as a
cosmetologist and a chemist and i
thought oh god that's what i want to be
when i grow up i went home told my daddy
he said no you are going into the
medical field i didn't send you to
school so that you can go and do the
beauty thing and i thought wow so fear
shut me down i stayed in nursing and 13
years later i got my wings i got my
courage and i left i left nursing to
pursue my passion and my purpose and
that's why i'm here today i had to
change my focus to change my future wow
actually mr okay um has a message for
you um go ahead and roll the clip please
i see
me i'm very proud of you
and all your accomplishments
i do hope that you continue to be an
inspiration
for all young girls around the world
[Music]
and continue to inspire them to achieve
their goals
congratulations
[Applause]
i'm
sorry oh my god
he saved my life
and the life of so many other women oh
my god
thank you truly saved my life and
because of him so many women have been
touched because of one person
having faith in another i'm sorry oh my
god don't be sorry
i feel like such a lucky fly on the wall
of this moment that you so deserve oh my
god oh my god
cindy i i just can't wait to see what
you do next and please let's stay
friends and in touch and continue to
shine a light on you know everything
that you're doing because i just think
the world of you and your you can check
out her products online at diva by
cindy.com and thank you for being on the
show thank you so much
connect with you and help you with your
vending machine i'm here for you yeah i
didn't have guidance because i i totally
couldn't pull it off thank you so much i
think you have a lot to teach
what an inspirational wonderful awesome
woman we chatted with cindy recently and
she has not slowed down she launched one
of her vending machines on a military
base in virginia and mr o'fay has asked
her to mentor some of his students i
love this we'll be right back to spill
some more secrets about season two don't
go anywhere
[Music]
plus one celebrity
we're back to bring you more
[Music]
the new season of drew premieres
september 13th
thank you for checking out some of our
favorite season one moments season two
kicks off monday and we'll be coming to
you from los angeles all week long and
we have so many surprises in store for
you
should i spoil a couple now
all right
well we're dedicating one day next week
to all things emmy with our friends from
entertainment tonight and this year's
m-e-m-c cedric the entertainer i know i
love him and kevin and michelle
plus the super talented
billy
eilish is stopping by
she has two number one albums under her
belt at age 19 and just so much more i
mean people wear t-shirts with her this
she means so much to people including me
and i'm really looking forward to
sitting down with her
okay and we'll be back um with more
memorable moments and behind the scenes
secrets tomorrow and mark your calendars
for the big season 2 premiere on monday
september 13th i love monday
see you then
[Applause]
[Music]
you